Takže koncept fundamentalismu je v podstatě spojen s
konceptem měření v kvantové mechanice
před tím, než byla kvantová mechanika vyvinuta
vědci obecně věřili, že pokud máš systém, který je
vědci, že pokud máš systém, který je
v určitém stavu
a provedeš na něm měření, dostaneš
dobře definovaný výsledek
v kvantové mechanice to tak už není, můžeš mít
systém, který je v perfektně dobře definovaném stavu
a přesto, když provedeš určitá
měření na něm, můžeš dostat náhodné výsledky
takže abych ten koncept ilustroval, musím
přinést koncept superpozice
superpozice je koncept, který tady není intuitivní
je to systém zobrazující
několik lineárních kombinací stavů
zároveň a můžeš si to představit
třeba jako rádiovou vlnu nesoucí
mnoho různých frekvencí, na tom
není nic kvantového
co dává superpozici kvantovou příchuť, je fakt
měření systému
tak to ilustruju na příkladu
představ si, že máš systém šipek
a připravíš systém
tak, aby všechny šipky ukazovaly doleva
a pak jdeš a
zeptáš se systému: jsi nahoru nebo dolů?
a protože šipky ukazují doleva, což lze
vyjádřit a popsat
jako lineární superpozici mezi
nahoru a dolů, dostaneš
výsledky z padesáti procent nahoru
a z padesáti procent dolů, když se zeptáš: jsi nahoru?
dostaneš ten výsledek od systému
a pak můžeš připravit jiný
jiný stav systému, kde mají
polovina šipek nahoru a polovina
dolů a zeptáš se na to samé
a dostaneš stejný výsledek
jsou to dva velmi odlišné systémy
a ty jsi o tom přišel o tuto informaci
protože jsi se zeptal na hodně
jak teď zjistíš, jaký je mezi nimi rozdíl?
oba systémy jsou velmi odlišné
protože v prvním případě jsi připravil systém v
čistém stavu a na systém
se můžeš zeptat a dostaneš deterministický
ne náhodný výsledek a ta otázka je: jsi vlevo nebo vpravo?
řekne ti stoprocentně, že vlevo
v druhém případě neexistuje žádná otázka
kterou jim můžeš položit a dostat stoprocentní odpověď, protože
je to směs, protože je to mixture
takže když se zeptáš vlevo nebo vpravo
bude to náhodné, protože polovina je nahoru
a polovina dolů, když se zeptáš nahoru nebo dolů
stejná věc, bude to padesát procent
jak to souvisí s kvantovou náhodností?
takže si to můžeš představit jako
hod mincí, bude to panna nebo orel
ale není to jako hod mincí vůbec
protože když hodíš mincí
jediný důvod, proč neznáš výsledek, který dostaneš
je ten, že neznáš
energii, s jakou jsi minci hodil, úhel hybnosti
okolní podmínky v místnosti
a tak dále, takže kdybys znal všechny ty
proměnné, mohl bys předpovědět pannu nebo orla
jsou to proměnné, které jsou skryté pozorovateli
a mnoho let si vědci mysleli, že existují
podobné proměnné v kvantové mechanice, které se
projevují jako náhodnost
a nebylo to až do
přelomové práce Johna Bella v šedesátých letech, kdy bylo prokázáno
že to tak není
a dnes každý fyzik
uznává, že neexistuje žádná
teorie skrytých proměnných, která by byla kompatibilní s kvantovou mechanikou
takže je opravdu pravda, že když měříš systém
příroda náhodně odhaluje výsledek
nezáleží na tom, jak dlouho o tom přemýšlím, pořád mi to
přijde úžasné